what's the other thing that progressives
are all going for right now they're
really into war have you noticed this
because the right right now and the
conservatives are basically saying hey
how about we stop giving this guy all
the money you know he's got nukes there
could be a problem here all the anti-war
voices are really on the right right now
there's a sliver of it on the left there
really is but most of it's on the right
so you're seeing the worksters they're
all going pro-war uh here's Jon Stewart
in March of 2022 uh you know and he's
he's into zelinski and defending the
place and whatever we got to do this I
got to ask you before you go about
another comedian zielinski yes I mean
it's just an extraordinary extraordinary
extraordinary I mean for for look I'm a
comedian I know comedians we
I don't I don't know that we would be
able to rise to the challenge of being
in a movie about war like and you see
this gentleman's courage and tenacity
and the way that he's leading his
country it's it it's it's incredibly
moving and I just uh my fear for Ukraine
is that we're gonna get sucked into this
idea of a heroic narrative yeah while
these folks get surrounded in a
long-term Siege that's just going to
cause so much more death and destruction
so the reason I wanted to show you that
is it's pretty interesting it's like all
right that was about a year ago that was
11 months ago March of 22. John you
should be screaming right now that over
the last 11 months uh the Democrats have
been marching us towards War we are
getting closer to war it is fairly
obvious and when we find out who
actually blew up the nordstream pipeline
Hint it was probably us uh and as we
keep giving tanks and planes and
Munitions and things to Ukraine I mean
we are just funding their War so in
essence we are at War
[Music]
foreign